Everything they teach you
in school is a lie.
You want the truth?
The world is controlled
by shadowy elites
and shapeshifting
lizard people.
Let's talk about reptoids.
Be sure to follow
these do's and don'ts
to avoid
a diplomatic incident.
Do offer them a cricket,
mouse or vole
out of your pocket.
Fun fact about voles,
a vole ate my father.
Don't use loaded
phrases like
"Hissy fit"
or
"See you later, alligator."
Got it, be respectful.
So, when do we talk about
the orgies?
-Boo!
-Oh, come on!
What? Everyone knows
reptoids have orgies.
This is an HR meeting.
Andre, Myc, shut the hell
up or I will castrate you.
Ha! Good luck figuring out
which one of my tentacles
is a dick.
Tick question.
It's all of them.
I'm deciding, this is ok.
Oh god, this is an orgy,
isn't it?
Oh yes, yes it is.
Gavel, give me the gavel.
Give me the gavel!
This is it. It's happening.
Hello HR, who's ready for
some gross misconduct?
I'm sorry sir,
but you tested
positive for iguanarrhea.
Motherfucker!
I wasn't done.
Iguanarrhea, clawmydia,
sssyphilis, scalebies,
explosive cloaca disease,
oh yeah,
and mushroom herpes.
Wait,
what was that last one?
Reagan, you're the life
of this party.
That's the most natural
smile I've ever seen
out of Mark Zuckerberg.
So, the song Shake It Off,
was about how I shed my skin
ever 1,000 years,
and the song Bad Blood
was about how I drink blood
out of my Grammys.
A toast to blood.
Safe some blood
for Paul Rudd
I gave you my kidney.
And it was delicious.
Reagan, meet my favourite
reptoidsentatives,
Barb Shrike
and Zarthax Griswold Walton
of the Reptoid High Council.
Good evening,
Your Lizardness.
Oh, we're not
that important.
It's not like
we control the world.
All rise,
for the reptilian anthem.
Let's get down to lizness.
We reptoids
have had a great decade.
Thanks to propaganda
in the media,
we have made society
more tolerant of our kind,
from the Geico Gecko
to The Shape of Water.
We even got K. Rool
in Smash!
We did it, everyone!
The world temperature
is rising.
The time is coming brethren.
Soon we shall
fulfil the prophecy,
overthrow humanity
and become the true rulers
of the world.
They say that every year but
they're never gonna do it.